this video is brought to you by junebe i
got me a strawberry
drink right here and then we spin it
like this thank you very much
i just wanted to put the plug in man
i'm telling you i got my caffeine double
fist that [ __ ] baby
i got i got four caffeinated drinks on
here you don't tap that out no he like
he like holds one there and then yep
that's it feels good
bam like that and it goes you didn't see
his legs
that's how i [ __ ] girls somebody slapped
me from the back
wait who wait who's the somebody there's
a third person
i hire a person just to slap my single
time it's gotta be just reactionary
no slap means no go yeah what does that
say to you ninja
i like to create jobs that is true
all right so this story here
is about this man who
is really highlighting how certain
people will go to
great lengths to avoid being held
accountable for their actions because
this man
faked his own death to avoid going to
jail
but a typo gave him away most people
don't want to go to jail
true i don't want to go to jail would be
funnier if
he wanted to fake his own death because
he didn't want his parents to see his
report card
that would have been like really way
funnier
for sure or like he picked his own debt
so that
he didn't want he don't want to pay for
child support oh no
people do i'm sure that happened that's
gotta happen one more example one more
example
he faked his own death so he didn't have
to pay the bill
when um he goes to eat lunch with his
friends well
i think that one takes the cake okay
thank you that might have actually been
like third place for me but really
really
okay that was a hard one you gotta you
gotta fake your own death at the
restaurant now
before like when the bill comes i gotta
use the bathroom and then you just gotta
figure it out you time it out with your
buddy who owns an
ambulance and you say hey can't come
back pick me up all right cool
oh
i like the report card one mode he's
like a 30 year old man
he's afraid of him you don't know asian
families girl
he's not even a f it's like a b-minus
watch out
anyway so this man named robert 25 years
old
uh from new york he now faces up to
four years in prison if he's convicted
guilty of this scheme uh and so that is
four years in addition just do it to
pending sentences
oh for earlier guilty pleas
to charges of possession of a stolen
lexus and attempted grand larceny of a
truck
which are the punish that's the
punishment he was avoiding like trying
to avoid
and there's no set amount of years for
that yet not that i know of i always ask
this question but i never know what
larson
is like theft what do you think it is oh
it's like a bunch of stuff right yeah
it's like taking
the personal property taking someone
else's possessions what's the difference
between larceny and theft
i don't know not a grand robbery a
difference between
larceny i know the answer but i can't
answer a second question in a row
because they never use it in like
regular like i larsen that fool
and most well it's not like yo i theft
that fool
yeah yeah but you're you're a thief
you're not a larson
whenever you become a grand i don't know
i have the answer grand is over
uh uh like 500 bucks or whatever there's
a lot oh
so there's petty theft and then there's
grand theft so like
anything under a certain value amount it
becomes grand theft so it's grand theft
auto when you like steal like a car that
has value but it's
something really shitty like a really
bad car that's worth under 500.
then it's just like an auto automobile
also like a shitty a shitty car is just
petty theft
and that's like like yo that car that's
it's an
old piece of [ __ ] man even the law
judges your shitty car
i thought it was every anything under
500 bucks but my the value might have
changed well it depends on the
jurisdictions because they're what i
googled
the difference between larceny and theft
it says that they are
mostly the same thing so this is a
different word for it martini
is a theft i see yes anyway back to the
story
yeah word of the day i'm gonna launch
that boo
i'm the hell of theft
[Laughter]
okay so anyway he was scheduled to be
sentenced to a year in jail last october
for the theft related charges apologies
they did give
a year thingy for that anyway so he
ended up fleeing the state
and then he ended up convincing his then
lawyer to submit
this death certificate which was given
to the lawyer by
his his girlfriend the the criminal's
girlfriend
and then so the lawyer apparently didn't
like he saw that it was fine
because he claims that he had no
knowledge of the fact that it was a
forgery
and so the lawyer turns it in and then
the department
like the they end up looking at it
they're like
the [ __ ] they spelled registry wrong so
that's how they ended up getting caught
from that typo
so you can see it here certificate
of death actually looks legit too really
legit but then if you
look here registry
pixel nation right oh the s-i s-i
instead of i-s
somebody don't know how to spell oh yeah
they typed everything out they didn't
just like
find a form online and just copy
registry i think they're the kind of
people that ignore the red squigglies
you know what i mean oh it's true they
could have saved
him what if the counter the counterfeit
certificate
programs don't have the red squigglies
oh they need to know
photoshop doesn't have that they should
have done it on i thought photoshop was
really good these days
what if that was just a real clerical
error those won't happen
this would be a template yeah it would
be a template
and so the not only that was like that
was obviously like the clearest sign of
the fact that it's forgery but also
red flags were the different fonts like
the different fonts
used actual one and the back of it was
like a newspaper they're not the proof
you had said that uh he had convinced
his lawyer
that's how they worded it does that mean
like
convinced as in like okay so if the
lawyer actually didn't know then this
girlfriend of his
hands alerts it says hey lawyer he died
yeah here's a certificate of death and
laura's like oh [ __ ] i must be crazy
the guy died yeah and then when he gets
caught because it's a fake thing the
lawyer is like
not in trouble for this it seems like it
yeah because now he has a public
defender
since the lawyer was like he's out i'm
not saying [ __ ] this
that's something i was thinking about
where i was like you know when all this
way fair cabinet shows coming out with
the kids
i'm like man if i caught someone messing
around with tyka
and like do i want to kill this
[ __ ]
because if i kill him i go to jail
right for life what good am i to taika
then in the long term i mean in the
short term i'm like [ __ ] yeah i [ __ ]
destroyed the [ __ ] that [ __ ]
up my kids
and they crown you royalty in jail
what are you in here for i killed the
[ __ ] child molester
oh [ __ ] this guy is [ __ ] he's dope
he's a hero
but i don't get to hang out with taika
or do i
uh unless ty could kill somebody too and
he comes and joins you or do i not kill
him
and then just do the regular system [ __ ]
like call the cops
so i could be there for taika but then
my heart's not satisfied
would your heart be satisfied if you
beat this man to a pulp but didn't kill
him
and then he sues you and wins
that's why you have to kill them no but
then at least no because then
he'll still be at home with with tyka
and then like the lawyer would be like
well clearly it was [ __ ] warranted
self-defense just blind him and cut out
his tongue oh yeah yeah
that's pretty cool how long is that like
10 years old but he can't talk against
you
you can't see you can't if you go up to
a mug shot line up he can't pick you out
i like that oh i see where you're going
thank you for the solution cut off is a
political
pretty easy to point out like the buff
asian oh no then just stand me next to
him he won't know who it is
he doesn't have any eyes i took out his
eyeballs and cut out his tongue and cut
off his penis
i've cut his penis and i saw it in his
ass whoa let's move
a lot of work okay what's more rewarding
getting
the one guy or the organization let's
recall their ass
because like i was thinking about it too
like we when we were um
in the lack of cramps right obviously
the people that were getting caught
are like the bottom barrel people and
sometimes
people that are forced to do it like for
example sometimes you think a drug
smuggler is someone who comes over on a
fishing boat but we all know that the
guy was forced
usually they get stopped and then people
throw drugs in there and say hey guess
what we're going to kill your whole
family unless you
you do this so then but then the da
catches them they're like
we got it we got pablo escobar but it's
like you didn't get [ __ ] you got an
innocent fisherman right
so in this case what if the guy that we
catch
isn't really a pedo but he's forced to
be
that and then we gotta we we lost the
chance of going up the chain
because you caught the person that would
have squealed
that's why you torture them you get the
information
and then they disappear and then we cut
off their tongue
and then so the uh the penis in the
butthole i want to be a part of the
team that finds the whole organization
that's the goal who's involved in these
things that's dangerous
yeah i didn't choose a life of law
enforcement so i wouldn't know
but i would like to donate or
help somehow you know if i could find
one of those so you want to be part of
the team
that like sits in a dark room and like
they're like you know the
actual you know government organizations
they don't actually like you know
represent this they're kind of like
covert
there's a giant like board and like red
like string yarn
is like yeah but like there's a dude
throwing a dart at like the lead
question mark yeah silhouette guy you
want to be on that team i want to be the
guy
this paper's all over the floor yeah i
want to be the guy
that buys the building hires
all the top guys from fbi and whatever
and i call it the children savers
right like lifesavers but for children's
and then like
we have an agency it's like a big c you
know like
it's a new organization like a man named
c
asian c asian c you know that's good
agency
and then everyone's working there and
i'm
behind the whole [ __ ] double glass
thing and i'm watching and i'm like
you guys don't even know who i am but i
made this happen [ __ ]
you know that's the best if it's double
glass can't they see you doing that
it's like the other one he's looking at
himself like
you don't know who i am
it's like why is that standing like that
the guy just accidentally installed it
the wrong way
i bought the other side of the office
look at like that
i love it with the same hair and
everything
oh that'll be so cool and i'll just be
the janitor of the organization and no
one will know
that i put it together everybody else on
the other side sippy coffee who the [ __ ]
is this guy yeah
[Laughter]
and then they're out there catching all
these bad guys mmm
you're gonna love this and uh like this
other story we have
it's a pedo avengers well oh [ __ ]
i'm not gonna give you too much because
we're not we're gonna talk about that
story stay tuned till next week
[ __ ]
on pedal avengers children squad
brought to you by asian c and junebe
jubilee out there to catch all the bad
guys
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos
and i know it's been a million years in
the making but we
finally got just kidding news merch
yup so make sure you go down to the
store below and you can run around
yeah you can get a piece of jk news and
thank you guys for supporting
thank you bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you